okay so let me ask you another question
about that then so see one of the
problems that I've had because I've been
trying to look at the the potential for
our true relationship between Islam and
Christianity you know to the degree that
I understand Islam or Christianity which
of course there's plenty to understand
about both so it's no easy thing to
manage but there is this claim as well
that that that's widespread and rather
vague that that Islam is in essence a
religion of peace and but when I look at
the historical data say stemming from
the medina the medina time and then
moving forward and the fact that the
Muhammad was definitely someone who
engaged personally in warfare and in an
expansionist warfare it's not it's not
an easy thing for me to make the leap to
to comprehending or being able to accept
the claim that the fundamental doctrines
of Islam are peaceful are associated
with peace because it looks to me like
there's an element of it that's quite
militaristic and I've also thought that
let's say there's a religious element to
Islam and I mean this is not an original
thought obviously there's a religious
element Islam but there's also something
that's clearly more like a political
movement and more like a governmental
movement and that's also complicated by
the fact that there isn't any clear
separation between church and state and
Islamic doctrine as far as I can tell so
when we hear claims that are when claims
are made that Islam is essentially a
religion of peace then that doesn't seem
to be the case with the Medina end of
the theological discourse or the actions
that that emerge thereof and then part
of the problem is how do you reconcile
that with the contradictions in
relationship to the earlier earlier as
you say Meccan doctrines and it isn't
clear to me how that can be done so for
Dylan C exam as a political theory that
the believers should enforce it
complicated to enforce so number one
they argue in that condition so they
find that Muhammad in repair did not
give the methods a choice he can say or
can have no gods like I have Michael his
message was you guys are Washington for
our thoughts these are either you live
in a time of ignorance and I have come
the last messenger to convey to you the
like a life lesson and come with me now
what we see sweetie his actions in
methods not the messages of peaceful
it's the front repeating applied force
using put together an elation and attack
the mechanism that he described as a
polytheists and company in Medina he
does that in a sphere in which the
numbers of Muslims increase and these
are people who come from movement by
force then initiate everywhere where
people access Islam that is definitely
true it seen Islam is only after you
accept Islam as long as you refuse to
abide by Islamic law or accept to be
subdued by Islam you are at war that's
why they the Medina's make this
distinction between the house of Islam
feasts and the heart of war break and
the house of war is everywhere where
there are infidels and expert job of the
Muslims and the house of Jesus to
convert them so it's a religion of peace
insofar as its final utopian aim is the
cessation of conflict but it's the
cessation of conflict in part as a
consequence of of conquest absolutely ok
you know
yeah well that was more or less how I
understood it so when the claim is made
that it's a religion of peace then that
isn't precisely it's it's a sleight of
hand in some sense with regard
specifically to that phrase